[Musique]
merci franis nel buffet de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes sénateur du R
membre du groupe les républiains
président de la commission des lois ici
au Sénat on va largement revenir sur le
projet de loi immigration mais un mot
sur une autre actualité d'hier c'est
pour la première fois un garde d' saau
devant la justice Éric Dupont Moretti
devant la Cour de Justice de la
République jugé pour prise illégale
d'intérêt il se dit innocent il dénonce
une infamie a-t-il raison de se
maintenir en poste pendant la durée de
son procès c'est vrai que c'est la
première fois qu'un garde dessous en
exercice qu'on paraît dans la cour de
justice de la
République la présomption d'innocence
est valable pour tout le monde et et de
ce fait il peut considérer et il a
considéré j'imagine que le gouvernement
a considéré qu'il pouvait venir devant
la Cour en gardant ses fonctions de ce
point de
vue-l c'est pas choquant dans le
principe c'est sans doute un peu
compliqué euh dans la réalité des faits
bien sûr mais bon il en est ainsi il
faut maintenant que ce procès a lieu et
que euh à la fois le ministre et à la
fois le procureur de la République
procureur général donne leurs arguments
et que chacun puisse s'expliquer et
naturellement après les juges décideront
c'est sans doute pour lui un moment pas
facile euh évidemment euh il y a une
pression médiatique qui est forte il y a
une pression politique qui est forte et
toute l'alchimie de l'audience ça va
être de se préserver de tout cela pour
s'en tenir à la réalité des faits et et
et au caractère ou pas condamnable ou
pas des actes qui ont pu être pris donc
je crois que l'intérêt général l'emporte
c'est qu'il faut avoir beaucoup de
prudence beaucoup de recul et ne pas se
laisser emporter par des considérations
qui seraient pas des
considérations justes voilà c'est ça
l'enjeu voilà on peut pas en dire plus
on n'est pas dans le dossier on n'est
pas à l'audience j'ai siégé à cour justi
de la République il y a quelques années
je n'y siège plus je sais à peu près
comment les chose se passent et le gage
d'une qualité de justice c'est d'abord
sa sérénité avant tout il faut espérer
cela on va longuement parler du projet
de loi immigration puisque plus d'un an
après sa présentation vous avez entamé
en séance l'examen de ce texte hier à
16h un texte largement inspiré de vos
travaux mais toujours pas de compromis
trouvés sur l'article 3 on va revenir
sur tout ça avec notre re journaliste
parlementaire Alex
[Musique]
Poussard bonjour Alex bonjour Ian
bonjour François nel buffet bonjour et
Alex on l'a vu dans le journal le Sénat
donc entamé hier l'examen du projet de
dois immigration et dans ce débat il y a
toujours un désaccord entre les
sénateurs LR et leur allicentrce sur la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers tention
effectivement Rian les sénateurs LR et
les sénateurs centristes qui forment la
majorité au Sénat sont d'accord à peu
près à 98 % sur la version qu'il
souhaite de ce projet de loi immigration
sauf sur l'article 3 qui prévoit la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension un
article qui crée précisément et bien un
titre de séjour de plein droit pour un
étranger en situation irrégulière avec
plusieurs conditions il faut qu'il
réside en France depuis plus de 3 ans
qu'il travaille dans un métier en
tension pendant au moins 8 mois sur les
deux dernières années et le travailleur
n'aura plus besoin d'une autorisation de
l'employeur pour être régularisé alors
une majorité des sénateurs les
républicains veulent supprimer cet
article 3 car ils estiment que cela va
créer un appel d'air migratoire on va
écouter le président du groupe LR au
Sénat Breno rotaillo c'est une
formidable capitulation que d'aller
chercher une main d'œuvre bon marché
quand en France il nous faut encore
mobiliser une réserve extraordinaire de
travail qu'on ne mobilise pas au moment
je vous parle il y a plus de 560000
étrangers qui eux sont en situation
régulière et qui sont au chômage au
moment où je vous parle il y a plus d' 1
million de jeunes qui sont ni en emploi
ni à l'école 1900000 français qui sont
au RSA et 3 millions qui sont au chômage
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait alors Bruno rotaillot et les
sénateurs les républicains ont donc
déposé un amendement de suppression de
cet article 3 mais pour que cette
suppression soit adopté il faut les voix
des sénateurs centristes des sénateurs
centristes qui eux sont favorables à cet
article 3 et au principe de la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papiers dans les métiers en tension on
va écouter sur ce point la centriste
Isabelle Floren niz la situation de ces
travailleurs sans papier qui travaillent
parfois depuis des années sur notre sol
souvent dans des métiers pénibles ne
résoudra pas le problème soyons clair
ces personnes sont le plus souvent non
expulsable ils sont sur le territoire
depuis trop longtemps ils sont intégrés
ont souvent une famille inutile donc de
venir les voir grossir la catégorie de
ce qu'on appelle les niniis ni
expulsables ni régular
alors on va rentrer dans le cœur de la
négociation entre les LR et les
centristes pour essayer de trouver un
compromis et bien les sénateurs
centristes proposent une nouvelle
rédaction de l'article 3 qui le vide
quand même de sa substance plus de ces
de séjour de plein droit les
régularisations se feront selon le
pouvoir discrétionnaire du préfet au cas
par cas comme c'est le cas actuellement
depuis la circulaire Vals mais plus
besoin non plus d'autorisation de
l'employeur pour être régularisé jusqu'à
hier le président du groupe les
républicains Breno rotaillo était opposé
à cette rédaction de compromis des
sénateurs centristes car il souhait
uniquement une circulaire administrative
précisant et bien que les
régularisations sont décidées par les
préfets et le problème c'est que si la
majorité sénatoriale n'arrive pas à se
mettre d'accord sur cet article 3 et
bien l'adoption d'une version
sénatoriale de ce projet de loi
immigration pourrait échouer et
politiquement euh ce serait un revers
pour la Haute Assemblée notamment pour
le président du Sénat Jaral Larcher qui
depuis 1 an défend le rôle d'équilibre
euh de euh la haute assemblée par
rapport à l'Assemblée nationale où il
n'y a pas de majorité claire pour voter
les textes certains parlent même de
crise institutionnel si aucune des deux
Chambres du Parlement ne réussissait à
faire adopter ce projet de loi
immigration François Noë buffet d'abord
une question de calendrier est-ce que
l'examen de l'article 3 va être reporté
en fin de semaine à la fin d' l'examen
du texte justement pour laisser cette
perspective d'un accord entre les LR et
les centristes écoutez nous allons euh
continuer de discuter avec nos collègues
triste euh vous savez qu'à la commission
des lois euh nous avons décidé de placer
le débat sur l'article 3 en séance nous
y sommes euh s'il faut se donner du
temps on se donnera du temps si nous
n'en pas nous n'en avons pas besoin bien
nous ne le ferons pas naturellement donc
c'est pas c'est une réponse qui
peut-être ne vous satisfera pas mais qui
en réalité traduit simplement le fait
que si nous devons avoir un accord et si
nous pouvons avoir un accord il faudra
se donner le temps de celui-ci si nous
ne l'avons pas parce que chacun reste
campé sur ses positions mais qu' peut
avoir lieu aujourd'hui parce que dans la
suite logique de l'examen c'est
aujourd'hui que vous devez attaquer cet
Artic on a encore un peu de temps on on
a beaucoup travaillé hier mais la
journée d'aujourd'hui va être encore
consacrée aux dispositions de l'article
2 on a encore beaucoup de travail donc
on a encore un peu de temps en réalité
mais la question est c'est une question
de fond qui se pose c'est dans la mesure
où on voudrait régulariser des gens qui
travaillent dans des métiers en tension
présent sur le territoire depuis de
nombreuses années faut-il une loi c'est
un article de loi c'est ça général
certes avec des conditions mais de
caractère général ou faut-il au
contraire se placer sous l'autorité du
préfet dans le cadre de ce que l'on
appelle l'admission exceptionnelle au
séjour en clair du cas par cas pour
faire simple pour que tout le monde
comprenne nous sommes hostiles je parle
des républicains au fait qu'on a un
texte à caractère général qui
constituera une forme de régularisation
de tous ceux qui sont actuellement en
sur le territoire national en sitation
irrégulière et dans des métiers en
tension parce qu'on considère que ça
créerait un appel d'air et que
finalement les étrangers du monde entier
je j'exagère un peu mais dirait B on
peut aller en France
irrégulièrement c'est sans papier
travailler et finalement on se fait
régulariser vous imaginez l'effet que ça
peut avoir et puis l'autre hypothèse et
là on n'est pas d'accord et l'autre
hypothèse c'est de dire certes on peut
prendre conscience qu'il y a des
difficultés et dans ces conditionsl
passons par l'admission exceptionnelle
au séjour qui est une une procédure
traditionnelle chez nous à la main des
préfets qui étudient les situations au
cas par cas et qui permet de résoudre
ponctuellement des cas ça c'est déjà
beaucoup plus sérieux enfin ça nous
paraît beaucoup plus sérieux voilà donc
je crois que ça l'est en fait donc il
faut qu'on arrive à TR avec des
conditions naturellement qu'on arrive à
trouver un point de un point d'équilibre
si on le veut à défaut il n'y aura pas
de il n' aura pas de de d'accord et le
risque de ne pas avoir de texte mais
alors quel pourrait être le point
d'équilibre quelle serait la et bien
nous allons euh euh continuer d'échanger
avec euh avec nos collègues pour voir si
on peut trouver euh ce point ce point de
chute euh nous ne l'avons pas pour
l'instant disons les choses telles
qu'elles sont
euh donc voilà on on on est encore un
peu
tempsire on a le temps le le compromis
je je le garde pour moi comprenez bien
que euh c'est assez c'est pas possible
de vous le donner maintenant mais il
faut savoir qu'on a l'intention mais qui
est le le le la pierre angulaire d'un
accord possible c'est le fait de dire
que cette régularisation si elle doit
arriver c'est du cas par cas et à la
main des préfet donc ça reste de
caractère réglementaire et ça n'est pas
une loi qui Gén qui régularise tout le
monde et justement la version de
compromis proposée par les centrrice
c'est un article mais qui précise que
ces régularisations se font au cas par
cas par les préfets vous François
nouelbffet personnellement est-ce que
vous pourriez voter cet amendement de
compromis s dans la position qui est la
mienne de président de la commission des
lois j'ai deux rapporteurs centriste un
une une collègue LR et j'essaie de tenir
tout le monde et de faire fonctionner
tout le monde c'est mon rôle donc si je
commence à poser des ocases j'aurai des
difficultés je vous le dis très
librement et très sincèrement je
souhaite qu'on trouve un accord bon mais
mais pas à n'importe quel prix pas au
prix de renoncer à des principes
fondamentaux qui sont les nôtres et qui
me paraissent parfaitement justifié j'ai
TR j'ose pas dire mais j'ai trop
d'expérience sur cette matière là depuis
très longtemps maintenant dans cette
maison pour savoir que ce que nous
allons écrire sera sans doute moins
important que ce qui va être ressenti ou
compris donc le message de ce que nous
pourrions écrire doit être parfaitement
interprété euh j'allais dire c'est
l'image qui va être donné en tous les
cas l'impression qui va être donnée et
pu est aussi importante pardon que
l'article qui va être rédigé donc ça
nécessite un peu de doité et un peu de
précision et puis ça nécessite puis de
toute façon nous discutons donc il y a
pas de je ne fais AUC aucun secret
là-dessus
nous allons essayer d'avancer et
cheminer nous avons un peu de temps
soyons tout à fait honnête nous sommes
aussi des gens responsables mais s'il
doit y avoir accord ce sera pas à
n'importe quel prix ça c'est clair si
jamais il n'y a pas d'accord et qu'il y
a un échec au final de l'adoption de la
version sénatorial du projet de loi
immigration ce serait un terrible
désaveux pour la Haute Assemblée écoutez
d'abord le pire n'est jamais sûr
ensuite le texte
globalement reprend vous l'avez rappelé
toutes les qui sont les nôtres très très
très largement pour ne pas dire très
majoritairement on voit bien l'état de
l'opinion et on voit surtout
concrètement la nécessité de de prendre
des de légiférer aujourd'hui et d'être
ferme je crois que dans cette matière là
il faut être clair si on veut avoir un
texte qui soit efficace il faut faire
preuve de clarteté il faut être très
ferme sur l'immigration régulière en en
baissant le niveau très nettement et en
priorisant l'immigration économique
qualifiée avec une maîtrise de la langue
et le respect des valeurs de la
République c'est un un point fondamental
il faut être très très dur je le dis
c'est tolérance zéro sur l'immigration
irrégulière donc simplification des
procédures capacité à expulsé on a mis
dans le texte le fait que pas de visa à
un pays étranger si on n pas les laisser
passer consulaires pour que ces pays
reprennent leur ressortissants donc
toute cette parti donc il faut aller
plus loin dans le rapport de force avec
les pays d'origine bien sûr il faut le
rapport de force avec les pays d'origine
sinon on y arrivera jamais c'est triste
à dire mais si tout le monde était de
bonne volonté les choses seraient
parfaites malheureusement ce monde n'est
pas fait comme ça donc il faut parfois
mais comment faire parce qu'on a
l'impression que Gérald haranin essaye
mais n'y arrive pas ben il faut donner
justement cette base légale cette base
légale qui viend du par sera dans la loi
française et qui donnera au gouvernement
quel qu'il soit la capacité de s'appuyer
aussi sur cette base légale ça c'est
important et qui enverra un message tout
aussi important au pays d'origine et
puis sur la sur
l'asile il faut tenter de tout faire
pour que la procédure d'asile je parle
bien de la procédure cesse d'être un
moyen d'immigration irrégulière
naturellement que l'on protège et qu'on
donne le statut de réfugié à ceux qui
relèvent de la Convention de Genève ça
ne fait aucun doute hein mais nous avons
aujourd'hui eu 135000 140000 demandes en
2022 on nous annonce peut-être 100000
160000 demandes d'asile pour 2024 et on
en accord 35 et 40000 ça veut dire que
tout le reste toutes les autres
personnes qui sont débouté droit d'asile
finalement nourrissent l'immigration
irrégulière et ne repartent jamais donc
il faut mettre fin à tout ça donc c'est
un enjeu très très fort nous souhaitons
travailler sur l'aide médicale d'État ça
Chun le sa justement et justement alors
là les sénateurs LR les sénateurs
centristes sont d'accord pour
restreindre le panier de soins de l'aide
médicale d'État la transformer en aide
médicale d'urgence mais un rapport qui a
été remis au gouvernement par claudévin
et Patrick stéphanini he Patrick
stéphanini qui est notamment l'ancien
directeur de campagne de François Fillon
lors de la campagne présidentielle et
bien ce rapport dit qu'il n'y a pas
besoin de toucher à l'aide médicale des
que c'est un dispositif qui est utile
notamment pour des raisons sanitaires
qui ne crée pas d'appel d'air migratoire
est-ce que la droite sénatoriale n'est
pas dans un symbole politique en visant
la me la question n'est enfin la
question n'est pas de ne pas soigner les
gens il est évident que on ne laisse pas
quelqu'un sans soin mais la question est
de dire entre une aide médicale d'État
dont il faut rappeler qu'elle profite
aux étrangers en situation irrégulière
sur le territoire depuis plus de 3
mois soit transformer en aide médicale
d'urgence c'est-à-dire que l'on ait un
paquet de soins déterminé par les
professionnels naturellement qui
s'occupe et qui soigne les personne en
cas d'urgence ça c'est impératif et il
faut cette aide médical d'urgence et ce
panier de soins il est fondamental on ne
laisse pas les gens en difficulté
personnelle avec un risque sanitaire qui
peut-être collectif que les choses
soient bien claires on ne supprime pas
les soins on fait simplement une aide
médical d'urgence et puis enfin faut-il
rappeler que lorsqu'on est en situation
irrégulière on n' pas vocation non plus
plus à rester sur le territoire
indéfiniment et quand on a un problème
de santé de quelque nature qu'il soit
mais qui n'est pas vital hein
naturellement et bien à ce moment-là on
doit pouvoir rentrer dans son pays parce
que c'est c'est le principe c'est que
quelqu'un qui est en situation
irrégulière il doit rentrer dans son
pays et à ce moment-là on se fait
soigner dans son pays mais bien sûr mais
j'insiste sur le fait qu'on maintient
l'aide médicale d'urgence et j'insiste
aussi que tout ça c'est aussi la
conséquence mais quels que soient les
sujets du d'un système qui n'est pas
efficace c'estàd qu'on ne répond pas
assez rapidement c'est tout le problème
de de l'immigration soit on est Agni sur
le territoire national et il faut le
savoir vite et je pense que c'est notre
responsabilité de dire rapidement à
quelqu'un vous êtes admis sur le
territoire national à tes condition pas
de problème vous rentrez dans le
dispositif mais il faut être également
en capacité de dire à quelqu'un qui ne
doit pas rester sur le territoire
rapidement vous ne pouvez pas rester sur
le territoire et vous repartez si on n'
pas cette efficacité là de toute façon
aucun système ne sera équilibré mais
qu'est-ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement sur l'ame parce que Gérald
ramanin il va dans votre sens il
soutient la transformation en Amu et
Élisabeth B pas du tout elle veut pas
modifier le à chacun ses problèmes à
chacun ses problèmes au Sénat euh nous
allons euh voter euh la mise en place de
l'AMU et si le texte sort du Sénat tel
qu'on le souhaite et bien l'Assemblée
nationale fera son œuvre on n'est pas
responsable de tout hier soir vous avez
voté des quotas d'immigration fixés par
le Parlement lors d'un débat annuel sur
ce sujet de l'immigration les quotas
d'immigration ça a déjà été voté sous
Nicolas Sarkozi en 2008 ça n'a pas été
appliqué finalement est-ce que ça peut
vraiment marcher est-ce que vous y
croyez vraiment à ce d'immigration une
fois de plus ce qui est essentiel c'est
d'abord qu'on a un débat institu enfin
qui soit dans la loi annuelle au
Parlement pour qu'on ait chacun puisse
donner ses orientations ses points de
vue et qu'on a un débat transparent y
compris que le gouvernement vienent
officiellement dire ce qu'il veut ou ce
qu'il souhaite et que le Parlement
puisse s'exprimer ça c'est quand même un
minimum ce qui correspond d'ailleurs je
rappelle quand même que le Parlement
étant
l'émanation du du vote de la population
premre premièrement deuxièmement euh se
donner des orientations se donner des
quotas des orientations c'est
fondamental faut bien se donner des
objectifs sinon on n arrive jamais sinon
on parle pour rien on se fait plaisir
mais il faut bien se donner des
objectifs alors chacun sait très bien
que euh c'est parfois
euh délicat mettre en place très bien
mais ça n'empêche pas le fait qu'il
faille essayer pour se donner des
objectifs c'est ça qui est essentiel
c'est une fois de plus je le redis le
message envoyé à tout le monde et que
chacun comprenne bien ce que veut la
France et ça l'enjeu de ce point de
vue-là il est absolument essentiel il y
a un signal un autre signal qui vous a
été envoyé par le Président de la
République euh parmi vos demandes il a
celle d'avoir un référendum sur
l'immigration parmi les demandes des
républicains dimanche soir il a écrit
une lettre au chef de parti en disant
qu'il souhaitait élargir le champ du
référendum euh aux questions migratoires
vous allez saisir cette main tendue vous
le vivez comme une main tendue je vais
quand même commencer par dire que la
d'abord c'est un sujet constitutionnel
c'est pas ce texte qui va le résoudre
euh c'est dans le projet de loi la
proposition de loi le projet de loi cons
le la proposition de loi conselle pardon
que nous avons déposé au mois de mai
dernier ça fait l'objet de discussion du
groupe de travail qui se réunit autour
du président Larché d'ailleurs demain
matin pour vous donner un scoop si vous
voulez he demain matin à 7h nous y
serons ça fera partie de nos débats donc
qu'est-ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que la modification de l'article 11 qui
permettrait de pouvoir ouvrir la phase
du référendum sur les sujets de cette
nature nous paraît tout à fait utile
elle est absolument c'est nécessaire
ça permet sur des sujets fondamentaux
d'avoir une consultation en direct de la
population est-ce que le Président de la
République fait un pas vers nous plutôt
que nous vers lui la réalité c'est que
le Président de la République fait un
pas vers nous puisque c'était notre
proposition c'est notre proposition que
nous en débattons demain je vous l'ai
dit dans notre groupe de travail autour
du président Larcher et donc c'est
plutôt une nouvelle intéressante qui
nous arrive reste en définir maintenant
les conditions ce qui n'est pas le plus
simple mais mais vous avez vous
l'accueillez bien parce qu' Brot il a
dit on n'est pas les perdre de l'année
en parlant de de cette oui parce que
c'est un peu la façon de vous dire que
c'est une volonté qui était la nôtre et
que c'est nous qui avons l'idée vous
savez en matière politique il y a un
principe c'est comme en droit en fait de
meuble possession vos titres
c'est-à-dire que celui qui a l'idée et
ben il l'a pour toujours alors le jeu
consiste souvent à aller plus vite que
les autres la réalité c'est que nous
avons annoncé cette volonté depuis
longtemps c'est quand même notre idée
notre projet et si le président de la
République il vient c'est parfait merci
Alex à tout à l'heure et on continuera à
parler de de ce projet de loi
immigration ce sera évidemment le débat
du club on va aller chez vous maintenant
François Noël buffet on va à Lyon
retrouver Marien trompette bonjour merci
d'être avec nous directeur départemental
adjoint du rô pour le journal Le Progrès
et vous souaitiez vous Marien évoquer
l'avenir de la métropole de Lyon oui
bonjour monsieur buffet vous aviez lancé
l'année dernière une mission
d'information sur la métropole he parce
que le fonctionnement de la de la super
collectivité dirigée par les écologistes
faisait faisait débat était décricrié
par les maires euh considéré comme trop
vertical trop abrupte et tenant pas
assez compte de leur avis vous aviez
formulé à l'époque des recommandations
et puis en septembre coup de tonner
Étienne blanc votre collègue sénateur
lui est plus radical il veut déposer une
proposition de loi avec Alexandre
vincandet pour la supprimer et revenir
en quelque sorte à son ancêtre la courli
euh ma question c'est tout simple vous
en pensez quoi et est-ce que vous
pourriez voter cette proposition de de
loi tout d'abord il faudra qu'elle soit
déposée et on va commencer par ça mais
la question c'est pas tellement ça en
fait euh je comprends bien qu'on veuille
essayer de trouver des coins entre nous
mais c'est pas la question de fond la
question de fond est est-ce que la
métropole de Lyon collectivité locale
est utile plus utile et plus opportune
que le PCI précédent qui était la
communauté urbaine la réponse est
complexe oui pour un certain nombre de
sujets mais elle pose d'autres problèmes
sur d'autres sujets premier point sur
1500000 habitants avec avec un budget de
plus de 4 milliards d'euros par an c'est
tout de même pas anormal que les
habitants du territoire puissentexprimer
directement pour élir leur président en
tous les cas sur un plan démocratique ça
ne me choque pas bien au contraire il y
a des points positifs dans cette fusion
on on l'a relevé dans le rapport à
savoir le fait de par exemple d'avoir
les politiques sociales avec les
politiques économiques ça c'est tout à
fait intéressant en terme de pertinence
et d'efficacité mais il y a des
difficultés et la difficulté c'est le
rapport entre les élus de la métropole
et les maires qui effectivement ont le
sentiment parfois c'est avec réalité
d'ailleurs d'être tenu à l'écart d'un
certain nombre de sujets donc est-ce que
l'on peut sans forcément revenir en
arrière de cette évolution
institutionnelle trouver un chemin qui
permette de renforcer le pouvoir des
mèes au sein de cette collectivité je le
crois je le pense c'est-à-dire que je je
suis convaincu que dans l'organisation
actuelle on peut nettement l'améliorer
dans le fonctionnement de la métropole
et dans le fait que les maires soient
mieux associé mieux entendu voire même
obligatoirement entendu donc il faut
trouver ce chemin-là et pas forcément
casser l'ensemble du système je rappelle
d'ailleurs que on a deux effets on a un
effet structurel lié au texte lui-même
et un effet conjoncturel parce que les
équipes qui sont arrivées en 2020 ne
sont pas celles qui étaient avant il a
pas la même expérience pas la même
vision des choses et et donc ça
nécessite aussi une adaptation mais je
ne suis pas naïf objectivement nous
avons besoin de renforcer le pouvoir des
maères au sein de la métropole de Lyon
donc on peut travailler là-dessus je
pense sans trop de difficulté on a même
des idées très précises là-dessus
enfin revenir en arrière encore
faudrait-il avoir
l'accord du département du rô h parce
que y compris pour lui ça nécessite de
remodifier toute l'organisation qui a
été mise en place dans le nouveau
département du rô donc ce n'est pas
aussi facile que ça contrairement à ce
qu'on alors on peut évidemment dire que
c'est facile que tout en dépose un texte
et que tout va bien mais ça n'est pas la
réalité euh la réalité elle nécessite je
pense un peu plus de de travail Marien
vous avez une autre question pour
François Noël buffet sur votre ancienne
mairie François Noë buffet la mairie
d'oulin oui ça vous surprendra pas euh
demain il y a un vote important monsieur
buffet c'est c'est B les villes d'houlin
et pierrebénit vont décider de de
fusionner euh demain mercredi hein je je
rappelle que vous avez été maire d'oulin
durant durant 20 ans euh voilà question
assez rapide aussi depuis que le projet
a été annoncé il y a des voix qui
s'élèvent pour dire que les habitants
auraient dû être conçus
par référendum est-ce que vous le pensez
aussi ma conviction personnelle est que
oui en réalité dans les textes lorsqu'il
y a fusion de commune il y a nécessité
de consulter la population sur une
organisation officielle il se trouve
que il y a un petit problème juridique
c'est qu'à l'occasion d'un texte en 2019
on a oublié que la métropole était
devenue une collectivité locale et
qu'elle n'appartenait plus que et que
les communes n'appartenaient plus à une
à une à une pardon je vais AR à une
collectivité à Unci pardon excusez-moi
et que les communes n'appartenait plus à
un PCI mais appartenait à une
collectivité locale donc il aurait fallu
modifier le texte mais la réalité de
fond c'est plus important finalement que
la réalité presque juridique en la
matière c'est que sur des projets aussi
importants qui engagent des communes
queles que soient les communes dans le
cas particulier je trouve malgré tout
que il faut
organiser la consultation oui je pense
que c'est mieux naturellement Marien un
mot sur la Une du progrès d'ailleurs
quel que soit ce qu'on pense qu'on pense
que ce soit bien ou pas bien mais ce
sont quand même des territoires
importants a des popul en nombre dans
habitants ça fait du monde hein oui un
mot sur la Une du progrès dans son dans
son édition de
Lyon dans son édition de Lyon revient
évidemment sur ce
fiver assez mystérieux qui s'est produit
ce weekend c'est une femme juive qui a
été poignardée à Lyon et on fait le
point sur l'enquête et voilà on a le les
proches de la victime qui nous ont qui
nous ont parlé donc on en sait un peu
plus aujourd'hui l'agresseur s'est fait
passer pour un livreur c'est le titre du
progrès merci Marien d'avoir été avec
nous un mot François Noël buffet de
réaction à ces actes antisémites en
général he plus de 1000 a dit Gérald
armanin dans la métropole de Lyon
notamment ce weekend il y a un
restaurant cacher de villeurbane qui a
été recouvert de de taace antisémite
comment on répond à ça il faut être
absolument ferme et très déterminé pour
lutter contre ces comportements
d'ailleurs tous les comportements
extrême quel qu'il soit et
singulièrement ceci qui nous rappelle
une histoire dramatique que nous
heureusement nous n'avons pas vécu mais
que nos parents nos grands-parents ont
connu c'est inacceptable il faut dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont c'est
inacceptable dans notre pays donc il
appartient évidemment aux forces de
police et la justice de les santionner
extrêmement sévèrement c'est insuffisant
c'est nécessaire mais insuffisant il
appartient aussi je collectivement à
faire une prise de avoir une prise de
conscience sur l'extrême gravité de ces
actes et il ne doit pas y avoir de
faiblesse merci François Noë buffet
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure on
suivra bien évidemment sur notre Anne la
suite du projet de loi immigration
article 3 ou pas on verra ça cet
après-midi merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous